ja und bei allem was sich gerade bei den
gesetzesverschärfungen tut gibt es immer
noch dinge die wirklich unglaublich sind
und die ein sprachlos machen wie diese
bilder hier zeigen und zwar sechs
punkten zu kaufen frei zu verkaufen
kindersex unten kann man sich ganz
einfach bei amazon bestellen wir haben
das gestern ausprobiert und sind
geschockt man kann sie sich wirklich
einfach nach hause liefern lassen
ja und genau das soll verboten werden
das fordert auch sylvia pantel
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete und sie ist
jetzt bei mir im studio guten morgen
frau kannte wir haben gerade die bilder
gesehen warum ist das überhaupt noch
erlaubt
also es ist ein zustand der nicht geht
dass das erlaubt ist es hatte sich bis
dato noch keiner darum gekümmert
wir sehen ja gerade wenn man genauer
hinguckt dann findet man fälle von
kindesmissbrauch ich arbeite schon lange
dafür um die strafen zu verschaffen
und jetzt geht es eben auch darum das
einüben an puppen wie man dann hinterher
mit kindern umgeht ist so grauenhaft und
wenn man sieht wie lebensecht diese
puppen sind man kann sie bestellen von
135 bis und man weiß ganz klar es sind
kinder sexpuppen und das gehört für
meine begriffe verboten der zoll wenn er
sieht dass solche lieferungen ankommen
und dann eben ausgeliefert werden kann
nichts machen weil die puppen sind legal
jeder weiss wer dahinter steckt jeder
weiß was damit passiert und da es eben
nicht zu therapeutischen zwecken
verwandt wird sondern frei verkäuflich
in jeden haushalt wo man dann eben
frisch frei einüben kann wie man dann
später mit den opfern umgeht ist das ein
zustand der ist für mich nicht
hinnehmbar und deshalb müssen wir
schnellstens auch etwas tun und das
verbieten sie haben gerade schon
angesprochen man kann die größe
auswählen man kann auch das aussehen aus
wenn also die haarfarbe die augenfarbe
was geht in ihnen vor wenn sie so was
hören es ist nur widerlich ich selber
bin mutter von fünf kindern wir haben
jetzt auch zwei enkelkinder
wenn ich mir vorstelle dass jemand dort
mit meinen kindern oder enkelkindern so
etwas praktiziert wird mir schlecht und
das wird es mir aber auch wenn ich mir
das für andere kinder vorstellen
und deshalb muss hier schnell gehandelt
werden ich bin jetzt schon seit über
einem jahr daran
innerhalb des bundestags hier eben ein
gesetz zu schaffen dass diese puppen
schnell verbietet weil nur dann kann man
handeln alles was legal ist damit können
sie werben
amazon wirbt damit sie bekommen es
direkt ins haus egal in welcher größe so
etwas gehört verboten
zumal ich ja immer weiß welche
pädophiler sich dahinter verbirgt die
wie gesagt zollbeamten oder sonst die
wissen was in dem päckchen drin ist
können noch nichts tun weil es ein
legaler artikel ist und ich finde dass
alleine die vorstellung dass man sich an
solch einer puppe erst vergeht und
danach eben kinder sucht ist für mich so
schlimm dass dieser gegenstand ganz ganz
schnell verboten gehört ja klare
botschaft dankeschön frau pantel fairen
besuchen vielen dank auch dass sie sich
für dieses verbot einsetzen und fassbar
dass es derzeit immer noch erlaubt es
vielen dank dafür ja danke für die hilfe